et son plein la province n'était pas en
reste
nord au sud et de l'est à l'ouest de
l'hexagone
l'annnonce de la victoire du candidat
socialiste a été accueillie par des
défilés spontanée de gens à pied ou en
voiture avec des concerts d'avertisseurs
de chant qui prenaient souvent la lure
de prendre en compte deux champions
beaucoup de balles spontanée un peu
partout à lille à tour à nice à rennes à
grenoble entre autres ailleurs on défile
parfois bicyclette en brandissant des
roses comme à toulouse ou bien en
décorant de fleurs les pare chocs de
voitures comme à albi une carcassonne en
alsace lorraine la bière a coulé à flots
dans bien des mairies et epinal la
municipalité a offert à ses administrés
un feu d'artifice c'est ainsi que les 10
mais a souvent pris des allures de 14
juillet anticiper bien monsieur jacques
séguéla c'est vous qui avez imaginé la
campagne publicitaire autour de la
candidature de monsieur françois
mitterrand est ce que ces fêtes d'hier
soir correspondent
est ce que vous auriez vous même
organisé je ne sais pas parce que le
métier de publicitaire n'est pas
d'organiser des fêtes il est de définir
un homme ou un produit et de de faire
éclater cette vérité et je crois que les
publicitaires de france aujourd'hui
peuvent être fiers leur métier va entrer
dans l'histoire de france car c'est la
première fois en france qu'un candidat à
la présidence de la république appelle
une agence de publicité pour l'aider à
mieux ce communiqué et qui le reconnaît
officiellement
alors monsieur séguéla la force
tranquille et l'autre chemin c'est de
vous c'est le monsieur françois
mitterrand aux sétois difficile à dire
parce que vous savez près de 200 slogans
qui ont été présentés non seulement à
françois mitterrand mais à toute
l'équipe autour de françois mitterrand
petite campagne absolument collective il
y avait personne à l' agence qui en cuir
travaillé pendant six mois sur cette
campagne françois mitterrand est
d'ailleurs formidable titre et je ne
peux plus dire qui a qu'un et à quel
moment mais
il est dans l'ensemble des textes qui
ont paru certainement l'auteur qui le
plus important mais est ce qu'on peut
avoir une idée des slogans qui ont été
refusées par exemple où il y en a qui a
été refusé que j'ai sur le coeur c'est
l'élan mitterrand monsieur qui laisse
n'aimait pas du tout et qui quand même
gêné monsieur mitterrand d'une équipe
qui voulait signifier ce qui s'est passé
ce grand concurrent
ce grand courant populaire qu'il fallait
déclencher la france tranquille ça a été
aussi calculé en envoyant en comparant
ce que faisait le concurrence le faisait
monsieur giscard d'estaing qui avait une
image plus nerveuse peut-être oui mais
surtout c'est la réalité de ce qu'est
françois mitterrand roger hanin
lorsqu'il décrivait tout à l'heure
françois mitterrand donner la définition
de la force tranquille et là où françois
mitterrand je crois a réussi à faire la
différence en communication c'est que il
s'est prêté au jeu de la communication
il a choisi un publicitaire il a vu très
souvent une fois par semaine pendant six
mois avant même la campagne et ensuite
pendant la campagne et la demande à son
buteur de tours son micro c'est à dire
de traduire en un mot et un visuel ce
qu'était le fond de sa pensée et le fond
de son être
angers n1 on voit mal de même monsieur
mitterrand a accepté d'être vendu comme
un produit
ça lui a été facile où est-ce qu'ils
s'étaient rebellés
non il s'est pas révélée s'était c'était
ma grande surprise au début j'ai pensé
que ça ne marcherait pas et puis je
crois qu'il s'est prêté à cette image a
à ce processus à ce procédé c'est pas un
vilain mot qui consiste à mieux se faire
connaître et accepter enfin tous ces
symboles et je me souviens de la
première première réunion passant de
communication où tu souhaitais comment
dirais-je définir l'image de françois
mitterrand où il est un petit peu
disséquer met en pièces entre guillemets
coire mis en équation et je crois qu'il
s'est très très bien prêter à cette
analyse on pourrait dire et puis ensuite
je m'en vendre comme un produit mais
c'est pas tes gens à désarmer c'est pas
du tout ça c'est communiqué de même
qu'un produit essaye de vous dire voilà
quels sont mes qualités et puis voilà
quels sont mes défauts quand ils jouent
le jeu de la vérité françois mitterrand
très objective loin a dit voilà qu'elles
soient mécaniques bien alors justement
il est ce qu'il vous a confié qu'elles
étaient ses défauts justement qui
l'empêché de communication d argent il
va cacher aucun de ses défauts est
d'abord de ses défauts de présentation
physique qu'ils ont tellement desservies
et qu'il a tellement améliorée parce que
je crois la publicité l'a déjà révélé
comme la publicité révèle d'abord les
annonceurs il s'est complètement mis
dans la peau de son vrai personnage qui
est la force tranquille et puis vous
savez tout ça est complètement
psychologique
on a enfin découvert un homme que
finalement on avait fait semblant de ne
pas connaître pendant des années et je
crois qu'on doit un peu à la publicité
mais faute plein d'humilité tout petit
peu à la publicité il faut pas croire
que on alla chercher le publicitaire et
en lui donnant des dizaines et dizaines
de millions on peut devenir président de
la république on devient président de la
république quand on n'est le président
de la république que veulent les
français
si seulement j'avais demandé son avis à
votre voisin su qu'il est l'homme
politique est un produit comme un autre
vient justement comme l'a dit messi
séguéla il est lui-même d'abord l'aspect
politique qui comptait ensuite la
publicité éventuelles je crois que j'ai
accès gras très bien défini ce que doit
être une campagne pour nous socialistes
et j'imagine que pour d'autres partis
une campagne de publicité une campagne
une publicité vous ayez le lapsus une
campagne électorale et d'une campagne de
publicité pour nous c'est un travail de
réflexion politique et la liaison entre
est responsable de la publicité et les
responsables politiques c'est très bien
fait il est un contact permanent
et pour en revenir à cette à ce projet
de l'élan mitterrand je dirais qu'on n'a
pas eu besoin
on n'a pas eu besoin de l'écrire sur les
murs d'en faire des affiches l'élan il
s'est manifesté
et finalement c'est un sens ça que la
symbiose entre politique et publicitaire
c'est fait je crois assez remarquable et
puis les là on risque toujours trébuché
bien rené rémond vous venez d'entendre
l'ensemble des commentaires à la fois
politique ensuite de celle de ceux qui
ont animé cette campagne alors c'est à
vous de me dire qu elle l a l'impression
que vous en que vous en garde et quelles
réflexions vous en tirez marc en
présence d'un changement tel que celui
d'hier soir l'historien et je pense que
une question historique est pas
étrangère à l'actualité c'est françois
mitterrand qui dans sa déclaration
d'hier soir évoqué le poids de
l'histoire et on sait à quel point ils
en aient pénétré la question que se
posent l'historien c'est ce changement
est une rupture ou les styles la
continuité et en la circonstance le très
précisément par rapport à la vème
république j'entendais hier soir
certains se demandaient vivons-nous déjà
dans le vième république à partir de ce
soir où est-ce la vème république qui
continuait même monsieur répond marc
dans sa déclaration on reprend un peu la
question puisqu'il évoque les principes
de la cinquième revue dont il a l'air de
penser que seule la majorité sortante et
est la dépositaire
la question me paraît appelé de réponse
la première en fonction des forces
politiques et la seconde par rapport aux
institutions les forces politiques
apparemment c'est une rupture puisque la
majorité d'hier et maintenant
minoritaires et que l'opposition d'hier
devient devient la majorité est beaucoup
disent après 23 ans serait plus réservée
moi j'hésite à employer l'expression 23
ans parce que aux origines
il faut revenir aux sources la vème
république le général de gaulle a été
appuyée et à vue se ranger derrière lui
pendant presque toute la guerre
d'algérie une partie des forces qui ont
triomphé hier soir contre les tentatives
de putsch
ouh ouh les barricades encore en 1965
car le général de gaulle l'effet de
gaulle si si on peut dire avait brouillé
en quelque sorte la frontière encore en
1965 contre françois mitterrand déjà
candidat unique de la gauche unie avait
obtenu quelques 3 millions de suffrages
d'électeurs de gauche s'est par la suite
seulement que le reclassement s'est fait
droite contre gauche à partir de 1968
1969 si bien que par rapport aux
origines de la vème république
l'aspect continuité me paraît presque
aussi important que l'aspect rupture à
cette différence près que la coalition
se forme autour de la gauche et et non
plus autour de la droite et paul quilès
l'évoqué de thaler cette coalition il
déborde les frontières de la gauche
classique et il ya incontestablement en
appoint des lecteurs qui sont venus en
renfort pour les institutions je prends
d'abord acte de ce que tout le monde
sans exception à a reconnu spontanément
immédiatement le résultat est que
personne ne conteste plus aujourd'hui
que le suffrage universel soit le seul
suivre ce soit lui qui dispensent le
pouvoir et ça c'est important car ça pas
toujours été vrai dans notre histoire
en second lieu la constitution n'a
jamais été mise en question
pendant la campagne électorale elle est
acceptée j'ai été frappé de voir hier ce
matin encore jacques delors réaffirmé
que le premier ministre procède du
président de la république que le
premier ministre propose au président de
la république ses ministres ce sont les
ternes même à peu de choses près du
communiqué qui avait surpris en son
temps en janvier 1959 lorsque le général
de gaulle avait choisi michel debré
c'est à dire que cette pratique est
devenue en quelque sorte le bien le bien
commun alors tout n'est pas joué puisque
reste posée la question
qu'adviendrait-il si avait un désaccord
entre le président et la majorité de
l'assemblée la question de date pas
d'aujourd'hui
on s'est posés périodiquement on croyait
qu'elle allait être réglé en 1978 elle
n'est qu'à journée elle peut se poser à
la fin de juin ou plus tard à fronts
renversés puisque cette fois ci c'est le
président qui est gaucher ce serait lé
l'assemblée qui serait de droite et tant
que cette question ne rappelle et éviter
il restera toujours une équivoque sur la
nature de notre constitution et sur sa
capacité d'adaptation mais reste que le
changement et le passage de la
présidence de la république de la
majorité de droite à l'opposition de
gauche qui se fasse sans à-coups sans
secousses dans l'acceptation générale à
mon sens c'est la preuve que cette
constitution
elle est assez profondément enracinée et
que l'ensemble des français ne
souhaitent pas remettre en question la
règle du jeu
or ça c'est par rapport à lier au 19e
siècle où il ya toujours eu des
oppositions nombreuse a compté c'est la
règle du jeu
je crois que c'est un acquis fondamental
et qui prouve que la france est vraiment
un pays démocratique
mais rené rémond va quitter maintenant
un petit peu nos préoccupations c'est à
dire l'élection présidentielle pourvoir
rapidement avec gérard mérigots les
autres grands titres de l'actualité dans
le monde oui je vous propose daniel de
rester toujours à ce chapitre action
présidentielle puisque hier soir à la
joie des heurts opposaient la déception
des autres
quelques incidents mineurs il faut le
dire se sont produits dans le courant de
la nuit en particulier à paris un
habitant irascible du boulevard
beaumarchais a tiré sur quelques
personnes qui manifestaient bruyamment
leur joie à la victoire de françois
mitterrand rentrant de la place de la
bastille il n'y a fort heureusement pas
eu de blessé puis coluche coluche et
quelques-uns de ses amis ont été
agressés dans un restaurant du quartier
des halles coluche a dû être soigné dans
une pharmacie ses blessures ne présente
pas de gravité l'une des personnes qui
l'accompagnaient en revanche a été plus
sérieusement touché en marge de ces
événements et quelques minutes après
l'annoncé de la victoire de françois
mitterrand la direction des douanes
françaises a pris la nuit dernière des
dispositions pour empêcher toute fuite
de capitaux vers l'étranger
les instructions ont été diffusée à tous
les services demandant une surveillance
accrue des résidents français aux
frontières surveillance accrue également
dans les aéroports à l'étranger le
ministre de l'économie du land 2
c'est à karlsruhe en allemagne fédérale
a été assassiné la nuit dernière à son
domicile
les inconnus se sont introduits dans sa
chambre et ont tiré six balles de
revolver sur monsieur herberth carrie
âgé de 61 ans il a été tué sur le coup
les auteurs de l'attentât ont réussi à
prendre la fuite les responsables de la
police pense qu'il pourrait s'agir d'un
attentat politique
menahem begin menace de faire intervenir
l'armée de l'air israélienne contre les
bases syrienne installés au liban
là où sont disposées les missiles sam
6,7 menaces du premier ministre
israélien intervient au moment même où
l'envoyé spécial du président américain
reggane entame une série d'entretiens
avec les divers responsables temps à
beyrouth et à damas et un jérusalem où
cet émissaire du président reagan sera
dès ce soir en provenance d'istres à
d'israël toujours cette information
samuel flattot sharon le député a été
condamné ce matin par un tribunal à
trois ans de prison dont neuf mois ferme
pour fraude électorale et corruption
samuel flattot sharon avait vous en
souvenez peut-être déjà dû quitter la
france où il était poursuivi par les
autorités judiciaires à son arrivée en
israël il avait fait campagne et s'était
fait élire au poste de député
lech walesa au japon le numéro un du
syndicat solidarité et polonais est
arrivé à tokyo à l'invitation de ses
homologues japonais
c'est à tokyo qu'il a appris l'élection
de françois mitterrand lech walesa a
estimé que s'il l'avait été élu c'est
qu'il le méritait c'est au peuple de
décider at il dit qui doit devenir
président dans leur pays
c'est ce matin seulement il ya quelques
minutes que nous avons appris qu'une
forte explosion s'était produite samedi
dernier au terminal pétrolier situé dans
les îles shetland au nord de l'écossé
et ce au moment même où la reine
d'angleterre s'y trouvaient l'origine de
cette explosion est encore inconnu on
pense toutefois qu'elle peut être lié
aux événements d'irlande du nord des
menaces d'attentât avait effectivement
été adressée aux responsables de ce
terminal pétrolier quelques heures que
juste avant
la visite de la reine d'angleterre reste
pour être complet la météo et il s'agit
de voir le temps qu'il fera demain
laurent broomhead je crois n'est pas là
pour l'instant de le rendre illégal que
nous retrouvons tout à l'heure lors du
raid étaient bien là mais il ne viendra
pas parce que malheureusement nous
n'avons pas le temps de passer la météo
vous la verrez ce soir dans notre
journal tout cas vous la connaissez déjà
puisque si vous avez suivi ce matin 7h
et 9h laurent broomhead vous l'a
expliqué parfaitement et longuement
convenu qu'on serait effectivement vous
essaierez décrit un homme nu voilà ça
n'était pas clair combien j'aurais qu'on
en vienne à l'élection présidentielle
avec la réaction des syndicats que vous
avez recueilli ce matin jean claude
renoult bah oui à la première chose
qu'on enregistre chez les syndicats
c'est bien sûr dans tous les cas
l'espoir d'une politique nouvelle une
autre politique plus favorable à leurs
revendications
ça si vous voulez c'est le sentiment
général
cela dit il faut nuancer d'abord il ya
les centrales qui ont soutenu françois
mitterrand la cgt la cfdt la fédération
de l'éducation nationale
pour georges séguy l'élection d'un
nouveau président de la république ne
supprime pas les patrons et les
travailleurs dit il pour concrétiser
leurs espérances légitimes devront se
mobiliser et faire preuve de lucidité
cela dit le ton a changé de lafayette la
cgt affirme sa volonté de contribuer au
succès d'une nouvelle politique la cfdt
à la cfdt on souligne que si le
changement est désormais possible
il ne peut pas être le fait d'un seul
homme il faudra transformer l'essai a
dit edmond maire hier soir mais il
faudra du temps et des états notamment
pour réduire la durée du travail
augmenter le smic tout tout de suite
serait une politique folle même espoir
pour la fédération de l'éducation
nationale andré henry qui souhaite un
grand élan syndicales demandent des
négociations rapides sur les dossiers
qui sont prêts enfin daniel bilalian il
ya les syndicats qu'il laissait leurs
adhérents libres de leur vote
force ouvrière la cgc des cadres et la
cftc andré bergeron nous disait hier
soir qu'il avait toujours pensé que la
victoire de la gauche se produirait un
jour ou l'autre c'est l'alternance at il
ajouté l'arc l'alternance pour lui c'est
d'abord de rencontrer françois
mitterrand pour lui demander non pas
un nouveau grenelle une négociation
globale comme en 68 mais des
négociations dossier par dossier enfin
jean menu pour les cadres de la cgc jean
bernard pour le ctc souhaitent eux aussi
rencontré le nouveau président pour lui
rappeler ses promesses
viens nous n'avons pas encore de
réaction du côté du cnpf il y aura une
réaction du côté des petites et moyennes
entreprises monsieur bernasconi vous
l'entendrez dans nos prochaines éditions
on va terminer parce que nous sommes
très en retard non pas par une
déclaration d'un homme politique non pas
par monsieur qu'il est semée par francis
lalanne francis elle n'a rien à voir
avec les élections législatives mais en
tout cas ils s'intéressent à la vie de
son pays il était hier soir à la
bastille je voudrais simplement vous
demander ce que vous faisiez hier soir
la vessie pourquoi vous y est allés
est-ce que vous avez ressenti mais s'est
sorti de chez moi je sais dans le
coltard parce que je reviens de tourner
alors vous dormez un peu est bon et j'ai
senti chez moi j'ai vu les gens qui
faisaient la fête dans la rue cris on a
gagné c'est la fête et où j'avais pas vu
ça depuis une éternité
et puis bon j'ai appris que mitterrand
avait été élu et m'a passé un coup de
fil comme quand on chantait on nous
faisait la fête alors moi je suis un
vieux fêtards alors à chaque fois une
fête à faire je vais la faire et puisque
je suis allé faire surtout c'était à la
bastille c'était fêter le départ de
giscard d'estaing plus qu'autre chose
parce que quand je je suis pas au ps et
et vous sentiez concernés quand elle me
sentais complètement concerné comme tout
le monde d'ailleurs parce qu'on a mis
tous pleins d'espoir dans ce changement
rendez pas compte mais un mec comme moi
fils jeune j'ai passé vingt ans sous le
même régime
alors tout d'un coup que ça change comme
ça c'est serré c'est un petit peu comme
si on s'enlève du pied une paire de
pompes trop petit quoi ça fait du bien
je pense que ce sera le mot de la fin on
a rien à ajouter quelque chose à
rajouter quelque chose alors allez-y
c'est que maintenant on a un nouveau
président et on a plein d'espoir et on
attend on attend que les promesses
soient tenues
merci francis lalanne le choix si je
peux conclure bien je peux avoir le mot
de la fin bien je dois simplement avant
de vous dire aurevoir simplement vous
indiquer que ce soir de 20h30 à 22h nous
présenterons un journal plutôt une
émission spéciale consacrée à ces
élections présidentielles présentée par
patrick poivre d'arvor
douze français interrogeront trois
leaders du parti socialiste français
après l'élection de monsieur françois
mitterrand voilà cette édition est
terminée je vous souhaite une excellente
après-midi sur antenne 2 heures voire
à demain
oui à mon tour je voudrais vous rappeler
que la rédaction d'antenne 2 vous
proposera également en après midi cette
fois à 16 heures
20h hier soir bonsoir à tous 20 heures
hier soir apparaît sur notre écran
dessiné par l'ordinateur de ses deux
yeux ni wayne bull le visage de françois
mitterrand le candidat de la gauche
les français ont donc élu un président
socialiste ça ne leur était pas arrivé
depuis 23 ans
notre estimation de 20 heures était
presque parfaite puisque la dernière
statistique officielle du ministère de
l'intérieur donne 51 75 % au président
mitterrand et 48,24 % un monsieur
giscard d'estaing c'est une très
confortable victoire pour françois
mitterrand une victoire qui va au-delà
du simple rassemblement de la gauche
il ya eu des moments de liesse notamment
à château chinon et à la bastille je
vous propose d'y revenir avec jacques
merino
date heure trente il ya soir à château
chinon devant l'hôtel du vieux morvan la
foulée sympathisants réclame le français
mitterrand il apparaît sur une terrasse
accompagné de sa femme danielle s'est
déjà l'entousiasme une heure plus tard à
la bastille l'entousiasme devient énorme
s'amplifie dans une gigantesque fête
populaire qui regroupe plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes cent
mille sûrement 200000 peut-être hommes
politiques et chanteurs se succèdent
devant une foule qui chante et qui danse
le commentaire alors devient inutile
regardez il ya là beaucoup de jeanne ces
jeunes qu'on n'avait pas vu dans les
meetings et qui semblaient indifférents
à la campagne électorale ils sont là
avec les gestes simples de ce qu'ils
ressentent exprime une forme de
libération
spontanément des parents dol se forme et
tout autour une bastille noire de monde
en
à minuit l'orage éclate violent landed
avec des énormes et claire et l'on
entend la foule scandait vive la pluie
vive le tonnerre dijoux mitterrand
le moment de la liesse et de l'émotion
passée vient celui des analyses de ce
que l'on pourrait appeler la nouvelle
donne politique alors premières
constatations le paysage politique
français à changer la gauche est
majoritaire dans de nombreux
départements français ce gigantesque
mouvement de bascule vous en doutez est
un événement historique pour la france
qui d'ores et déjà réuni pratiquement
les conditions de l'alternance
cette alternance elle ne sera toutefois
complète que après les élections
législatives c'est à dire le troisième
tour et ce troisième tour il est déjà
engagée depuis hier soir par la majorité
qui aggravent ses divisions daniel brel
oui parce qu'elle se dispute tout
simplement la place de chef de file
alors ce matin à 10 heures monsieur bart
a proposé de prendre en main le flambeau
de rassembleur de la majorité
parlementaire actuelle dénonçant je cite
la fraction qui a joué le sort de la
vème république à quitte ou double il
faut comprendre même s'ils ne sont pas
nommés jacques chirac à une fraction du
rhdp jacques chirac lui pour montrer
qu'il était le meilleur conducteur donc
de cette majorité a reprises son thème
d'une politique de changement et de
renouveau et souhaité qu'il y ait un
seul candidat dans chaque département
pour l'ensemble de la majorité ce qui
supposerait un accord préalable entre
toutes les composantes de la majorité
il y à quelques instants monsieur pinton
qui est le délégué de l'udf a lancé un
appel pressant au président sortant pour
qu'il prenne lui-même la tête du grand
rassemblement qui unira tout ce je cite
qui partagent l'idéal de liberté et de
justice de la vème république
enfin dans la soirée nous ne l'avons pas
encore un communiqué devrait annoncer
que contrairement aux propositions du
rpr l'udf chouette que chaque formation
aille sous son drapeau au combat et que
le mieux placé par est au deuxième tour
bien alors daniel maintenant dans le
dans le camp de la gauche c'est à dire
celui du du président élu et bien alors
dans le camp des socialistes
une réunion de groupe a été annoncé pour
cette semaine par monsieur gaston
defferre
alors qu'il sortait du conseil politique
qui s'est réunie au domicile de monsieur
mitterrand
là encore les préparatifs sont en cours
mais leur phase décisive ne devrait
intervenir qu'après la formation du
nouveau gouvernement
monsieur mitterrand a toujours dit vous
vous en souvenez sans doute que le parti
socialiste devrait voir au cours de
dégoter de négociation de discussions
avec le parti communiste
si un accord de gouvernement étaient
possibles mais pour cela il a précisé
qu'il faudrait que le parti communiste
modifie ses positions sur un certain
nombre de problèmes de politique
étrangère tels que par exemple
l'afghanistan
alors si la chose s'avère impossible et
bien il pourrait y avoir un accord
électoral de désistement mais je crois
qu'on peut ajouter qu il n'est pas exclu
que les socialistes pensent compte tenu
des mesures qui est social qui seront
prises avant les législatives
et compte tenu aussi du mode de scrutin
majoritaire et bien que après tout avec
ce scrutin et donc et ces mesures à eux
tous seuls
il pourrait avoir une majorité
confortable
merci daniel alors il fallait s'y
attendre les les milieux financiers ont
réagi à l'élection de françois
mitterrand les autorités de la bourse
ont décidé aujourd'hui de d'annuler
jusqu'à demain la cotation des valeurs
françaises il y a beaucoup d'ordre de
ventes mais pas de propositions d'achat
une douzaine de valeurs françaises
seulement pu être cotée sur le marché à
terme des valeurs reculant de 4 à 10%
cantons français bien une baisse de 1 et
demi à 2% mais c'est une situation qui
pensent qu'on devrait s'améliorer dans
les prochains jours alors je ne vais pas
vous livrer toutes les réactions des
gouvernements étrangers à l'élection de
monsieur mitterrand je vous livrerai
simplement les deux plus importantes
celles des états unis et celle de
l'union soviétique les états unis le
président reagan à féliciter je le cite
chaleureusement monsieur françois
mitterrand qu elle a assuré je cite
encore de sa volonté de travailler en
étroite relation avec lui fin de
citation le président reagan s'est
déclarée très impressionnée par la
victoire de françois mitterrand
et puis l'union soviétique vient de
faire connaître sa réaction officielle
par la voix de monsieur léonie debré
genf le chef de l'état et du pc
soviétique le président soviétique se
prononcent je cite pour un développement
dans tous les domaines des rapports
entre les deux pays
il a présenté à monsieur mitterrand
s'est vu du succès et au peuple français
ami je cite toujours c'est vous de bien
être et de prospérité
fin de citation voilà donc pour les
principales réactions à l'étranger
ah si la ville savait que nous ne
développons développons pas les affaires
de grandes politiques nous nous
préoccupons plutôt de la vie quotidienne
alors les développements les
commentaires les analyses et bien et
vous seront donnés à partir de 20 heures
ce soir
dans un premier temps 20h 20h30 notre
journal présenté par patrick poivre
d'arvor et à partir de 20h30 jusqu'à
21h50 une édition spéciale où les
principaux responsables du parti
socialiste et les conseillers du
président mitterrand seront pas opposé
mais répondront aux questions de douze
français que nous avons essayé de
sélectionnés pour leurs critères de
représentation
autrement dit la rédaction d'antenne 2
s'est mobilisée toute entière pour
essayer de se mettre au diapason de cet
événement que certains observateurs
qualifient d'une ère nouvelle
oh
eh bien il faut dire que pour cette
partie magazine de ces la vie
exceptionnellement ça arrive une fois
tous les secteurs nous avons un décor
vraiment grandiose celui de nos
confrères de la rédaction qu'hier soir
se sont livrés aux commentaires et
analyses de cette nouvelle situation
politique française
en ce qui nous concerne et bien comme
d'habitude nous resterons au niveau de
la toile cirée de toile cirée c'est quoi
c'est cette semaine l'unaf l'union
nationale des associations familiales et
c'est vous martine chardon qui vous êtes
occupé de nous présenter cette scierie
je rappelle simplement que lui n'a fait
partie de toutes les associations qui
sont au conseil d'administration de
l'institut national de la consommation
avec lesquelles nous avons décidé de
présenter des sujets qui les
concernaient directement vous avez
presque tout dit alors avant de voir
quels sont les principaux objectifs de
l'ina je regrette d'ailleurs enfin ce
n'est pas moi qu'il regrette c'est le
président du neuf c'est qu'on ignore
trop souvent encore ce qu'est l'unaf
alors je me propose de voir avec nous
les principaux objectifs du bien nous
regardons avec vue donc ce reportage de
présentation c'est parce que si on fait
créée en 1945 et modifié en 75 par une
réforme qui a élargi ses droits l'unaf a
gardé ses principaux objectifs
représenter l'ensemble des familles
françaises défendre leurs intérêts être
leur intermédiaire auprès des pouvoirs
publics domaine infiniment race que
celui de la famille allant des problèmes
de santé aux besoins de la jeunesse en
passant par la gare de l'éducation des
enfants les handicapés les problèmes du
logement et la situation de l'emploi
depuis soixante-quinze unaf également
pris en charge les familles étrangères
vivant en france familles souvent
vulnérables en raison de leur maître aux
ressources ou d'un niveau culturel assez
faible l'unaf à penser que celui qui a
quitté son pays pour apporter sa force
de travail
un pays voisin et bien pouvait
normalement avoir dans ce pays voisin
dans ce pays d'accueil
une vie de famille
allez faire venir sa femme et faire
venir ses enfants je sais je sais ça
pose beaucoup de problèmes et
aujourd'hui certains nous nous on plonge
le problème de l'emploi
mais nous demandons que les émigrés
d'une famille d'immigrés ayant chez nous
soit respectée quelle est la sécurité et
qu'on les considère comme des familles à
part entière par les familles font c'est
ya alors martin à partir de demain vous
allez nous présenter des expériences
menées par l'unaf sur le terrain des
expériences ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est que pour mener à bien son action
l'unaf s'appuie d'une part sur les
mouvements familiaux d'autre part sur
les udaf qui sont les union
départementale des associations
familiales
alors demain nous dirons dans les landes
et nous verrons un petit peu comment ce
que fait du das lied afd landes face
justement ce étrangers soit réfugié
politique comme les mondes
nous verrons un cours d'alphabétisation
qui était mené à bien pour les mondes
et puis nous verrons également une
action menée pour les familles
portugaises
on essaye de les reloger bien les
mosellans des peuplades d'asie du sud à
ce fonds qui vient du laos pour la
plupart bien alors martine peut-être
serait-il bon de donner dès ce soir nous
ferons chaque soir maintenant l'adresse
les coordonnées du neuf
alors pour vous les présenter peut-être
sur l'écran à moins que nous n'ayons je
n'ai pas sous la malade rien d'accord je
croyais que nul et je l'avais prédit
pour demain alors mon jean claude allan
et qui est bien renseigné 4e place saint
georges dans le 9e arrondissement 5
passes et ray je vous prie de m'excuser
pour avoir pas mais c'est pas très grave
et bien alors rendez vous est pris pour
demain donc pour noter cette adresse de
vinasse et surtout avec votre reportage
sur le terrain dans l'élan les skull
conflit était bon je n'ai pas eu tant le
goût déjà jean-claude visas liée là vous
aviez la parole vous allez le garder
vous vous êtes un petit peu évadé pour
votre chronique de ce soir il s'agit du
voyage vers les ânes je crois oui je
suis venu avec un beau globe terrestre
non pas pour mettre aux oubliettes mais
parce que ça fait rêver et pour vous
parler des
aventures d'un monsieur qui est allé
voyagé en inde etc a eu quelques
difficultés il allait pouvoir revenir
c'est moins glissant de projet au nom
oui par exemple mon désir de voyager
peut-être donc je vais vous parler des
mésaventures d'un jeune un jeune de
saint-hilaire dans le maine et loire qui
est parti en inde par l'intermédiaire de
nouvelles frontières et à l'aller il ya
pas eu de problème il est très bien
parti sauf qu'il est parti sans son
billet de retour alors qu'il avait payé
l'aller et le retour
il n'est pas parti car il voulait partir
vite et que le billet n'était pas prêt
car le billet était établi par le bureau
londonien de la compagnie aérienne
afghane ariana qui établissait le billet
pour le compte de nouvelles frontières
c'est apparemment un petit peu compliqué
mais c'est compliqué parce que c'est un
peu le secret des bas tarifs
nouvelles frontières comme d'autres
organismes pour obtenir des bas tarifs
cherche les compagnies qui proposent les
tarifs les plus intéressants et je crois
que le consommateur lui a commis une
erreur de partir sans ce billet de
retour dans dans sa poche
car ce billet devait être envoyée à
delhi et début mars et puis début mars
galvier n'était pas arrivé à delhi par
les jours sont passés ce consommateur
s'est impatienté il est intervenu auprès
de nouvelles frontières qui lui a dit le
billet parti de londres le 6 mars puis
le billet parti de londres le 10 mars
mais le 20 mars le billet n'était
toujours pas arrivé à delhi mondial
assistance a été alors contacté par ce
consommateur qui a envisagé donc son
rapatriement
mais entre-temps nouvelles frontières
est intervenu en disant ça y est cette
fois ci le billet est parti le 25 mars
je vous rappeler que je rappelle qu'il
devait arriver début mars
théoriquement à delhi et enfin le 4
avril comme le big n était toujours pas
arrivé mondial assistance a pris en
charge le rapatriement de ce voyageur et
puis le billet s'est évaporé dans la
nature vous avouerez c'est une affaire
qui n'est pas tout à fait banal j'ai
contacté nouvelles frontières qui estime
d'ailleurs être lui-même victime du
bureau londonien de la compagnie ariana
et d'ailleurs pour démontrer sa bonne
foi aux nouvelles frontières a décidé
d'offrir un billet d'avion en thaïlande
pour ce consommateur
mais cette affaire est assez exemplaire
et si vous préparez vos départs en
vacances pour cet été je crois qu'il
faut que cela serve de leçon et je peux
vous donner quelques conseils à la
première chose oui
la première chose à ne pas faire c'est
bien sûr de payer un aller retour et de
partir sans avoir le retour dans la
poche parce qu'après c'est quelquefois
difficile pour le récupérer
deuxième conseil c'est de bien
vérifier lorsque vous achetez un billet
sur quelle compagnie vous allez voyager
car il ya les compagnies qui sont
sérieuses et d'autres qui sont peut-être
un petit peu moins sérieuses ou un petit
peu mais peut-être moins bien organisés
de manière générale je crois d'ailleurs
qu'on peut peut-être déconseillé de
partir sur une compagnie qui est dans un
pays en guerre parce que c'est jamais
très très favorable du point de vue de
l'organisation
enfin dernier conseil c'est de bien
éplucher tous les tarifs hors savez-vous
noël que sur la ligne paris delhi si
vous voyagez par air france cela veut
peut vous coûter 3700 francs
mais cela peut vous coûter aussi 9580
francs selon les jours et selon toujours
la même compagnie selon lui jours selon
les vols du côté de nouvelles frontières
sur la même ligne vous avez quatre
tarifs différents 3900 francs
3500 francs 3380 francs et 3050 francs
et bien sûr selon les cas vous voyagerez
dans des conditions qui sont un petit
peu différente alors le problème c'est
de savoir quels sont les risques que
peuvent représenter les bas tarifs
et je crois qu'avant d'acheter avant de
choisir il faut vraiment ouvrir l'oeil
et ne pas avoir la langue est caché dans
sa bouche l'avoir bien pendue ouvrir
l'oeil pour bien regarder le détail de
toutes les brochures et poser toutes les
questions au vendeur pour ne pas se
faire piéger par ce quelquefois le moins
cher ce n'est pas forcément le plus
intéressant alors dites-moi jean-claude
or en voulant partir en voyage pour cet
été j'ai vu beaucoup de d'associations
ou d' agences de voyages il affiche un
prix sur les étalages et lorsque l'on
rentre ce prix n'est plus en cour oui
effectivement ça c'est en fait ce qu'on
appelle un prix d'appel
c'est à dire on marque sur la vitrine
vous pouvez partir chez pan tunisie pour
900 francs et quand vous entrez on vous
dira oui mais ça ça fait longtemps qu'on
a vendu tous ses voyages à mais par
contre si vous voulez partir en tunisie
pour 1500 enfants
on a tout ce qu'il faut curé sérieux
qu'une fois que le client est entré mais
il pourra repartir avec un voyageur
salle en guérir un prix d'appel c'est
pas bien et il faut pas hésiter
d'ailleurs à a protesté et intervenir
auprès d'une association de
consommateurs car c'est illégal
bien merci de tous ces conseils jean
claude alain valentini vous venez de
faire un grand voyage vous étiez au
japon nous en rendrons compte sur
antenne 2 et notamment dansé la vie avec
les reportages les parties magazine que
vous avez rapporté avec monique karr à
seulement comme il nous reste très peu
de temps j'ai simplement voulu avec
toute l'équipe de sylvie saluer votre
retour un petit mot pour nous dire
bonsoir oui un petit moment géant
japonais non dits sayonara pour dire au
revoir c'est à peu près tout ce que j'ai
pu apprendre durant ce voyage
merci vous voilà en tout cas vous avez
très bonne mine ne vous souhaite une
excellente soirée si possible sur
antenne 2 rendez vous demain à 18h30
pour une nouvelle édition de c'est la
vie au revoir à demain
vous vous souvenez de la série française
où mais voilà
où
ces bons petits pots nestlé 1,1 fait à
moi aussi j'aime ça du coup le corner
au revoir monsieur bah ça y est je les
retiens guen qui permet y est gelée
vendu tu perds mais oui bah c'est pas un
vrai métier vous des imitations salle k
way swiss et coumba ka ouest madame
mademoiselle messieurs bonsoir notre
programme de la soirée est légèrement
modifiée en effet en raison de
l'importance de l'actualité notre
troisième édition du journal d'antenne 2
se poursuivra jusqu aux environs de 21h
heure à laquelle antenne 2 diffusera un
film de la série hawaii police d'état
intitulé mille pardons par la suite aux
environs de 21h 57 une soirée musicale
musique différente puisqu'il y aura un
grand pianiste de renom muret pereira et
à 22h40 du jazz bonne soirée
aussi votre journal sur antenne
un monsieur bonsoir un journal
exceptionnel pour un événement
exceptionnel pendant plus d'une heure en
effet alors essayer de comprendre
pourquoi les français ont élu un
président de gauche
comment ils l'ont fait sur tout ce
qu'ils en attendent pour l'histoire sans
doute le symbole cette victoire de
françois mitterrand le symbole de ce 10
mai restera cette image de la place de
la bastille à côté de moi de ce grand
rassemblement populaire que l'on a bien
retrouvé à une moindre échelle dans
l'autre ville de province il y aura
d'ailleurs dans ce journal beaucoup
d'image beaucoup plus que de
déclarations politiques de réactions en
tous genres qui paraissent forcément en
retrait en regard de l'événement
l'événement s'est donc je vous le répète
une nette victoire de françois
mitterrand voici les derniers chiffres
officiels et définitifs 51 75 % pour
françois mitterrand soit 3 points de
plus exactement que valéry giscard
d'estaing cela donne vous le voyez en
chiffres plus de 15 millions 700 mille
pour l'un et près de 14 millions six
cent cinquante mille pour l'autre un
événement que vous allez donc pouvoir
vivre minute par minute depuis le début
c'était donc il y à tout juste 24 heures
rue de solférino au pc de campagne de
françois mitterrand dès 18h30 on savait
qu'ils avaient gagné à 20 heures c'est
la certitude
ils attendaient ça depuis 23 ans
à
colas
et aulas
à
vous êtes étudiant ya longtemps que j'ai
pas vu rue de marignan chez les
giscardiens le silence de la défaite
maintenant confirmé
il
comme à mi chemin de fer dure
et pis de pair
désespoir police
affiche du bleymard
désespoir folie
et chez les jeunes après l'abattement un
sursaut de colère la révolte contre le
mauvais sort vous demande ce soir aucune
manifestation publique
ce n'est pas la peine et cela ferait
simplement plaisir à nos adversaires
place de la bastille la fête populaire
ils seront 200 milles au pied du génie
de la liberté et cette fois ce n'est
plus pour revendiquer mais pour se
réjouir
la victoire
à
il connaît
et avec la musique de leurs vingt ans
les soixante huitards ont retrouvé leur
jeunesse
à
une heure du matin l'orage gronde sur
paris la fête sera écourtée par la pluie
ouais bah
château chinon premier face à face du
nouveau président avec les français
la foule est si dense que danielle
mitterrand mais pas un quart d'heure à
rejoindre son mari pour le salut aux
amis fidèles
la fête aussi en province un peu partout
les jeunes se rencontrent et se
réunissent spontanément comme ici à
strasbourg strasbourg un exemple
d'autant plus significatif que
mitterrand n'y a pas obtenu la majorité
à
une fête qui a duré jusqu'au petit matin
en alsace aussi l'histoire accueillait
mitterrand sur un air de reggae
donc pour ce qui s'est passé cette nuit
un mélange de liesse populaire et de
déclaration officielle la plus
importante d'entre elles étant bien
évidemment celle du président élu
françois mitterrand c'était à 10h30
environ à château chinon
je mesure le poids de l'histoire sa
rigueur sa grandeur
seule la communauté nationale entière
pourra répondre aux exigences du temps
présent
j'agirai avec résolution pour que dans
la fidélité à mes engagements
elles trouvent le chemin des
réconciliations nécessaire nous avons
tant à faire ensemble et tend à dire
aussi des centaines de millions d'hommes
sur la terre saurons ce soir que la
france est prête à leur parler le
langage qu'ils ont appris à aimer tél
mesdames et messieurs j'ai une autre
déclaration brève affaire avec giscard
d'estaing que je remercie de son message
j'adresse les voeux que je dois à
l'homme qui pendant sept ans à diriger
la france
au delà des luttes politiques et de nos
contradictions
c'est à l'histoire qu'il appartient
maintenant de jouer chacun nos actes
merci françois mitterrand qui donc
officiellement n'est toujours pas
présent à publier qu'on ne sait
d'ailleurs ce soir encore quand aura
lieu la passation des pouvoirs
ce peut être le 25 mai dans donc deux
semaines tout juste si l'on respecte le
calendrier et le septennat la durée
complète de valéry giscard d'estaing
mais ce peut être aussi avant cela
dépend essentiellement d'un accord entre
les deux hommes en attendant ce moment
françois mitterrand a passé la journée à
prendre un certain nombre de
dispositions bernardino
ce que je peux vous montrer de la
journée de monsieur mitterrand c'est en
fait la sortie de son domicile il ya
quelques instants en voiture monsieur
mitterrand était déjà sorti ce matin une
seule fois pour aller se recueillir sur
la tombe de son ami georges dayan au
cimetière du montparnasse
georges dayan est l un de ses proches il
était l'un de ceux qui croyaient en une
victoire prochaine
un jour où l'eau de françois mitterrand
journée de recueillement de calme et de
travail
le nouveau président élu n'est pas
encore en fonction et d'ici au 24 mai il
travaille avec ses collaborateurs comme
ce matin les membres de son conseil
politique comme cet après midi avec des
proches salir son entourage son
entourage de campagne il va travailler
le quinze jours qui viennent avec une
série de contacts à la préparation
vraisemblable des élections législatives
aussi à la formation d'un prochain
gouvernement c'est à dire dans
l'immédiat mais à ce sujet je peux vous
dire qu'il n'y a eu aujourd'hui aucune
fuite
alors du côté de celui qui reste encore
président de la république pour
l'instant valéry giscard d'estaing bien
la journée a commencé à chanonat et
s'est achevée il ya quelques minutes à
peine à l'elysée par une rencontre
importante avec son premier ministre
raymond barre comme qui les lundis à 18
heures raymond barre qui a bien répété
qu'il n'entendait pas devenir chef de
parti et le matin dans une déclaration
il n'avait pas prononcé le nom de valéry
giscard d'estaing mais il avait dénoncé
en revanche je seek l'immense
responsabilité d'une fraction des
membres de la majorité qui n'a pas
hésité à jouer au petit ou double le
sort de la vème république il est
difficile de ne pas y voir une pierre
dans le jardin de jacques chirac
nous verrons cela tout à l'heure avec
nos copains et paul amar sur place qui
nous annonce une future importante
déclaration du présent la république
d'ici la fin du septennat le prêt public
qui entend à je vois maintenant que le
pôle que nous entendre le public qui
entend donc s'adresser aux quelque 14
millions cinq cent mille français qui
lui ont fait confiance
qu'est ce qu'il y aura pas la mare dans
cette déclaration du père d'un public
lyon 648 français qui lui ont fait
confiance
en dépit des critiques et des trahisons
comme est dit et je le cite
sitôt après l'achèvement de sa fonction
présidentielle qui leur indiquera le
chemin à suivre pour défendre les
intérêts essentiels de la france chemin
qui n'est ni celui du front populaire ni
celui d'un affrontement rétrograde entre
la droite et la gauche mais celui du
rassemblement démocratique au centre de
la politique française déclaration
significative pour valéry giscard
d'estaing qui a passé toute la journée à
réfléchir le combat politique que
continue ils interviennent à roncq
publiquement sans doute le 24 mai date
probable de la passation des pouvoirs
en attendant il souhaite que cette
passation des pouvoirs que la succession
se déroule dans de bonnes conditions
il a donné cet après midi des
instructions nécessaires pour que
françois mitterrand dispose des
principaux télégrammes diplomatiques et
des informations du secrétaire général
bien noël copains a pris quelques notes
dans deux minutes tout de suite après
une déclaration de jacques chirac il
pourra intervenir donc sur ses
déclarations qui paraissent c'est
contradictoire donc de balle et giscard
d'estaing de raymond barre et de jacques
chirac mais avant de continuer à
détailler les différentes réactions du
monde politique patronale et syndicale
enfin que nous introduisions une rupture
un petit peu dans le déroulement de ce
journal en nous faisant vivre la façon
dont à régis une partie du pays qui
attendait une victoire de la gauche
depuis maintenant 25 ans ont choisi une
usine symbole et un quartier témoin
renault à boulogne billancourt et la
démence
chez renault à billancourt le travail a
repris ce matin bien effet une fois pas
un jour comme les autres dans les cars
au café dans les usines
la victoire de françois mitterrand fait
l'objet de tous les commentaires
on est content d'avoir des définitions
je vois un certain point vous allez
faire aujourd'hui par exemple
vous allez travailler comme les autres
jours
vous allez manifester votre ange noir
avant de manifester nature quand même
des choses je vais fêter la victoire du
terrain évidemment les mesures et
l'avait voté pour lui
maintenant si on veut des démunis d'un
gouvernement d'union des ministres
communistes c'est avec maintenant qu'il
faudra les féministes ministre a servi
ce passage où il fait confiance
bien sûr ça on a voté police et beaucoup
un peu confiance en lui oui on est jeune
on n'aurait pas voté pour lui et vous
habiller encore qu'est ce que vous êtes
en d'être solidaires ont fait les 35
heures par semaine à la défense c'est
sous une pluie fine que les cadres et
les employés ont retrouvé leur bureau ce
matin françois mitterrand élu on est
satisfaits dans l'ensemble en tout cas
un constat unanime les cadres et les
employés ont voté pour le changement
des ministres communistes au
gouvernement pourquoi pas on fait
confiance à françois mitterrand pour
être ferme et gouverner selon son
programme électoral
site réservé c'est tout c'est pourquoi
vous aviez vous aviez souhaité sa
victoire et puis si longtemps qu'on
sente il était temps non moi j'étais un
je suis intérimaire et je pense que ça
change
serais tu que c'est que ça change quand
c'est que les conditions de travail vont
être meilleurs
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
certainement les cadres en particulier
les employés à tous les échelons
pourquoi pas vous êtes jeune vous pensez
que c'est plutôt les jeunes qui ont élu
françois mitterrand je pense qu'il ya eu
certainement une une grande majorité de
jeunes qui l'ont élu effectivement la
suite j'avais et pourquoi vous craignez
cette élection je ne crois rien du tout
mais
et je vais juste un qui fait bien que de
toute façon je 18 que mon parti a perdu
mais je ne regrette pas parce que je
pense que il fallait peut-être un
changement et c'est dans le bon sens
ouais j'évoquais tout à l'heure a
justement la déclaration de raymond
barre la veille au soir jacques chirac
s'était déjà présenté un petit peu comme
le rassembleur de l'ancienne majorité et
le chef de la nouvelle opposition
c'est jean loup le scène qu'il a suivi
depuis le début de cette campagne qui
nous raconte sa journée d'aujourd'hui en
annonçant dès 20h40 hier soir qu'il
comptait s'emparer du leadership de la
majorité parlementaire devenu
l'opposition présidentielle jacques
chirac ne pouvait que s'attendre à de
vives réactions dans les rangs de l'udf
pourtant aujourd'hui aussi bien ici rue
tilsitt que rudy au siège du rpr on n'a
pas éprouvé la nécessité de répondre aux
propos des uns ou des autres
même les critiques de raymond barre à
propos de ceux qui au sein de la
majorité ont joué je le cite la vème
république à quitte ou double même ces
critiques n'ont pas trouvé d'écho ici
c'est que tout l'état major chiraquien
l'a dit aujourd'hui que pour elle que
pour les élections législatives promises
par le président françois mitterrand
on suit plus déjà les chances de tel ou
tel candidat dans telle ou telle
circonscription car non seulement
jacques chirac souhaite animer l'ex
majorité mais il s'en veut le fer de
lance quitte à minimiser l'action de ses
anciens partenaires de l'udf quitte
également à banaliser le rôle d'élément
dynamique que pourrait endosser pour la
circonstance valéry giscard d'estaing
les tensions demeurent attachés à une
société l'initiative de responsabilité
de liberté et pour tout que les choses
soient claires il ne manifesteront j'en
suis sûr à nouveau
or la clarté exige aujourd'hui l'unité
c'est pourquoi je propose que dans
chaque circonscription légiste est bien
un candidat unique désigné d'un commun
accord
défendre ses valeurs d'initiative de
responsabilité de liberté qui sont là
qui de la vème république et qui
pourrait demain être en cause
une chose est sûre ce soir jacques
chirac veut à tout prix garder
l'initiative
il a même annoncé cet après midi qu'il
tiendrait dans les tout prochains jours
une conférence de presse pour confirmer
ses choix ses espoirs mais aussi ses
volontés un copain giscard chirac deux
prétendants un une poste du chef de
l'opposition ça fait un peu trop
s'attendait bien une compétition n'était
pas si rapide et bien oui valéry giscard
d'estaing n'a pas attendu longtemps
après cette défaite pour montrer qu'il
était prêt à participer à nouveau au
combat politique mais il est vrai aussi
que jamais les mouvements qui composent
l'ancienne majorité les chefs qui les
dirigent n'ont paru aussi divisée et
qu'après cette élection perdue c'est
d'abord donc jacques chirac le premier
hier soir qui s'est présenté comme étant
un rassembleur et un recours ce matin en
lisant le texte de raymond barre bien
des commentateurs on pensait que raymond
barre se placer comme concurrent de
jacques chirac et puis finalement ce
soir on voit que c'est valéry giscard
d'estaing lui-même qui est relève le
défi et qui entre dans la bataille avec
d'ailleurs une certaine vigueur à dur et
il a des phrases très dur le mot de
trahison sera quand même très difficile
à avaler c'est pourquoi cette nouvelle
rivalité ou cette amplification des
rivalités entre valéry giscard d'estaing
et jacques chirac que peu pesé très
lourd dans la campagne qui va souffrir
si les deux hommes ne trouvent pas une
issue et voici déjà que l'udf et le rpr
r après s'être depuis bientôt 24 heures
rejeté la sur l'autre la responsabilité
de l'échec proposait tactique
radicalement différente pour cette
élection législative
jacques chirac donc nous on l'entendre
proposer une candidature unique dans
chaque circonscription et l'udf réplique
cet après midi par un communiqué qu'ils
proposent au contraire ce que l'on
appelle des élections primaires avec
bien sûr quand même un désistement
automatique au second tour des
négociations donc qui s'annonce très
difficile
à l'intérieur de l'ancienne majorité
après tout à fait complet résulte que du
côté du pc aujourd'hui rien 9 alors en
revanche la bourse comment at-elle réagi
mal les autorités boursières ont même
été obligés d'ajourner la cotation des
valeurs françaises qui était en train de
baisser et qui ne trouvait pas
d'acheteur quant au franc il affaiblit
assez sensiblement entre 1,5 et 2 pour
cent a commenté history de mémoire de
boursier on n'avait jamais vu ça
aujourd'hui la bourse de paris a salué à
sa manière la victoire de monsieur
mitterrand dès l'ouverture de la séance
un seul mot d'ordre résonnait vendée les
comics courait dans tous les sens
portant les ordres une heure et demie
plus tard en raison de l'abondance des
ordres devant les autorités tutelle le
ministère des finances décidé d'ajourner
à mardi la cotation des valeurs
peut pas dire que l'on n'a pas coté les
200 valeur de terme en tout
tenté
établie à l' équilibre et sur les deux
sens il y en a tout de même une presse
qui ont été cotées avec un décalage en
baisse de 10%
sur les 187 autres on a pu constater
qu'avec 10 % de baisse
on n'arrivait pas à l'équipe il faut
rappeler que les cours des actions
s'établissent suivant le jeu de l'offre
et de la demande
et si l'offre est trop importante le
marché déséquilibré et les cours
s'effondrent à 10% en baisse sur les
cours de vendredi par l'acheteur jusqu'à
demain donc les valeurs françaises sont
comme disent les professionnels réservée
à la baisse
que sera le marché demain il dépendra
peut-être des investisseurs
institutionnels 6,15 et autres caisse de
dépôt il est vrai qu'avec leur puissance
financière
ils peuvent s'ils le désirent équilibrer
le marché ce délai de réflexion d'année
à la bourse permettra peut-être d'y voir
plus clair et j'ai vu que le napoléon a
lui gagné 70 en une seule séance hier
soir le premier ministre avait donné des
instructions pour stopper toute fuite de
capitaux c'est ainsi que le service des
douanes de strasbourg avait lancé des
consignes particulières à ses agents à
un d'effectuer de sévères contrôles même
chose un peu partout en france
ces images par exemple vous le voyez
nous viennent de la région de bordeaux
on attendait évidemment avec intérêt la
réaction du cnpf fall guène nous
parvenir par la voix de françois ceyrac
n'est pas une déclaration de guerre ce
n'est pas non plus une franche
coopération d'abord surtout demandé
patron le respect de la liberté le
lendemain de l'élection présidentielle
les difficultés demeurent
elles ont non crise mondiale coûte de
l'énergie instabilité monétaire
inflation chômage
la guerre économique qui nous est
imposée exige des entreprises qu'elles
soient capables de faire face à la
concurrence étrangères sur nos marchés
nationaux comme sur les marchés
internationaux
cela suppose l'allègement des charges
qui pèsent sur les coupes des
entreprises petites moyennes ou grandes
et le respect de leur liberté d'action
du côté des syndicats vous avez pu
entendre dès hier sur ce même plateau
andré bergeron pour force ouvrière
andré chirec edmond maire pour la cfdt
jacques chérèque pardon pour la cdp et
tout à l'heure la cftc a demandé un
entretien au nouveau président de la
république en souhaitant que des mesures
concrètes soient prises en faveur des
plus défavorisés en répétant bien son
refus catégorique à toute remise en
cause directe ou indirecte de liberté de
l'enseignement
quant à georges séguy ils viennent nous
dire qu'il n'imposerait pas dès
maintenant d'exigence particulière une
réponse un participant nous ne
présentons aucune exigence précipitée et
il ya des problèmes la résoudre par des
traits d'autres par voie de négociations
avec le gouvernement et le patronat à
l'échelle des entreprises et des
branches professionnelles
tout cela doit prendre son temps
normalement et nous voulons que ces
négociations se déroulent dans la
meilleure sérénité possible pas de pas
trop de combativité de votre part la la
combativité vous savez à s'exprimer
d'une manière différente selon les
situations
des fois par la grève parfois aussi par
l'insistance engager des négociations et
par la fermeté de la discussion
en ce moment nous espérons que ce sera
toute façon là que les problèmes sociaux
seront résolus c'est super parce que ça
nous et est nous journalistes que le snj
syndicat national des journalistes a
demandé d'ores et déjà un entretien avec
le nouveau président la public pour que
soit garanti une véritable indépendance
des journalistes
force ouvrière et la cfdt ont formulé le
même souhait très fortement puisque nous
parlons avec les syndicats de ce qui va
à concrètement changer pour les français
dans la vie sociale et économique nous
pour essayer de voir ensemble noël
copains ce que le président peut d'ores
et déjà faire sans attendre d'avoir une
éventuelle majorité parlementaire nous
c'est que la constitution distingue le
domaine de la loi qui applique un vote
du parlement et le domaine réglementaire
et un gouvernement qui agirait sans
qu'une assemblée soient réunies ne peut
agir que dans le domaine réglementaire
alors c'est assez peut-être un peu
compliqué mais quand même est la
constitution énumère ce qui est du
domaine de la loi et se contente pour le
domaine des réglementaire de dire que
tout le reste appartient à ce domaine
alors et appartient au domaine de la loi
je cite seulement quelques exemples les
nationalisations d'entreprises
le système électoral tout ce qui touche
aux principes fondamentaux de la dea
ans national de l'enseignement du droit
du travail du droit syndical etc
je renvoie les téléspectateurs à
l'article 34 de la constitution pour la
liste exhaustive
voilà donc lancé mi temps on ne peut
rien faire contre dans le domaine
réglementaire un gouvernement pourraient
sans l'aide du parlement est décidée par
exemple le relèvement du smic le blocage
des prix est bien sûr entreprendre
prendre l'initiative de toute
négociation entre partenaires sociaux
également prendre des initiatives dans
le domaine international
alors est-ce que c'est nécessaire de
dissoudre l'assemblée pour obtenir 1
seconde et bien non ce n'était pas
nécessaire de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale on aurait pu près il fumait
bien le président de la république ne
pourrait pas dissoudre cette assemblée
pendant un an c'est à dire qu'il devrait
composer avec elle et former un
gouvernement tenant compte de la
composition de cette nouvelle assemblée
mais on sait que françois mitterrand
dans la foulée de son de son élection
présidentielle espère remporter les
élections législatives mais un élan
maintenant retourner en province pour
voir comment les français ont vécu cette
élection direction l'île tout d'abord
avec jean jacques dufour qui a enquêté
auprès de deux petites entreprises
il fut important de dire que l'une
d'entre elles étaient déjà en
autogestion depuis cinq ans
aujourd'hui il ya sûrement eu beaucoup d
usine où les ouvriers étaient heureux
comme un marc tube cette fabrique de
tubes en plastique ou depuis cinq ans
chacun une voix pour décider de l'avenir
de l'entreprise
après une longue occupation de leur
usine fermer ils furent 8 à faire
redémarrer cette affaire en investissant
leur hymne de licenciement dans la
société
aujourd'hui ils sont 23 salariés et
votre même leur salaire échelonné de
3000 à 8000 295 francs mais pour son pdg
et lui cette élection n'est canet c'est
qu'il faudra maintenant transformer la
hiérarchie des salaires c'est de 1 à 3
on a partagé les fruits de notre travail
vous voyez c'est quand même la joie dans
l'entreprise mais les gens sont sérieux
il ya aujourd'hui on aura pu
continuellement faire la fête mais je
pense qu'il ya un travail à réaliser on
le réalise et l'ensemble des
travailleurs
je pense que les travailleurs de renault
lundi à soir maintenant on va
s'accrocher et on sera plus libre
c'est ça l'espoir est disons qu'on a
marqué un essai et il faut qu'on le
transforme avec les élections
législatives un peu plus loin dans la
zone industrielle la société siat qui
emploie 8 personnes deux ouvriers
étaient présents dans l'atelier
ils nous ont livré leurs réflexions
d'après élection soit en résulte un
joueur c'est difficile de le prévôt
on nous a fait des promesses bien sûr il
faut attendre résultats quoi vous
envisager l'avenir comment au jeu
projetons pas dire plutôt contents ils
auraient préféré quand même jusqu'à leur
pdg est un ancien quart qui après avoir
passé 20 ans dans le textile et s'être
retrouvé au chômage il ya quatre ans a
décidé de monter une société dans un
créneau d'innovation il a pensé
fabriquer verre de sécurité et
aujourd'hui il estime qu'il faudra pour
essayer de résoudre le problème du
chômage et des pme et pmi
je pense que cette élection doit amener
un changement important dans la vie des
gens qui travaillent et dans ce contexte
là je souhaiterais que cette élection
puisse aider les petites et moyennes
entreprises à prospérer à créer des
emplois
et pour ce faire je pense qu'il serait
intéressant que le gouvernement prenne
des mesures d' aide sur le plan de ses
entreprises afin de diminuer les charges
qu'elle supporte pendant les années les
plus difficiles qui sont les années de
création et il se situe frais souvent
sur la base des deux ou trois premières
années d'existence une opinion patronale
plutôt confiante est elle représentative
et puis à l'autre bout du territoire
marseille c'est là que nous rejoignons
gérard belmas qui toute la journée à
musarder en compagnie
des pêcheurs et des commerçants il a
recueilli leurs différents témoignages
après cette élection de françois
mitterrand dans les calanques
si chère aux amateurs marseillette des
fameux cabanon voici les goudes dernier
port typique du coin 317 habitants en
hiver des commerçants et bien sûr des
pêcheurs des petits métiers qui marchent
parfois quinquas et qui attendent déjà
des changements de la part du nouveau
président mitterrand j'attends le roi le
premier sera pire nous fait savoir
j'attends beaucoup de monsieur mutants
au sujet de la vie familiale
j'attends beaucoup de monsieur
mitterrand sur tout ce qu'il a promis
pour la société française pour une union
de tous les français c'est ce que l'on
veut en france en ce moment et ce qui a
été pendant plusieurs décennies
abandonner ne travaille que pour payer
c'est tout une fois qu'on a payé noah
spécialisé à l'essayer 60 jours
quelle est la solution votre avis asus
en mémoire en ce qui concerne votre
métier d'épicés d'alimentation
quoi que ce soit - étranglée parce qu'il
ya certaines choses que ne prend même
pas la gorge en reçoit des patates de
tous les côtés surtout pour le petit cc
moscou enfin moi je me vois ici là ça
fait deux ans que je suis je reçois de
ces choses-là berra quoi c'est tout
juste si on peut tenir
nous pensons qu'une pour nos commerçants
qui dans cette élection peut apporter
peut-être un changement ça représente je
pense l'espoir de beaucoup de petits
commerces d'artisans scepticisme espoir
mais très rarement inquiétudes ici comme
ailleurs on est décidé a jugé au
résultat
vous savez que depuis le début de ce
journal notre parti pris est donc
d'alterner les réactions des français et
puis les commentaires et les relations
des hommes politiques car les
commentaires voici un an née raymonde il
faut revenir un petit peu en arrière
pour savoir comment ont voté les
français est d'abord rappelé qu'il
nouveautés nombreux c'est important
effectivement 24 heures heure pour heure
après l'annnonce de l'élection de
françois mitterrand on voit mieux se
dégager quelques évidences de la
profusion des des commentaires du
foisonnement les impressions et la
première évidence et c'est que les
français ont voté nombreux très nombreux
eux mêmes pour la métropole plus de 86%
c'est à dire très proche du résultat de
1974 qui constitue un record inégalé
mais en chiffres absolus c'est à dire en
nombre d'électeurs ayant effectivement
voter compte tenu de l'accroissement du
corps électoral le chiffre de 31
millions et quelques d'électeurs qui ont
déposé hier un bulletin de vote et de
beaucoup le plus élevé de toute
l'histoire électorale française et ça
paraît important parce que ça répond à
une question qu'on se posait depuis des
mois est ce que les français
s'intéressent à cette campagne
je crois que ça fait justice de l'idée
qu'ils étaient indifférents et pour
évoquer un un épisode mineur de la
préhistoire de diers l'effet coluche je
crois que hier la réponse est fait il
n'y a pas d'effets coluche car si est
vraiment il y en avait beaucoup qui
attendaient que coluche soit candidat
pour porter pour exprimer qui ne
s'intéressait pas à la campagne
électoraliste électorat s'est volatilisé
bon alors l'essentiel c'est qu'ils ont
changé de majorité s'allume alors
l'essentiel c'est que la majorité a
basculé depuis je dirais pas 23 ans par
souci d'exactitude car il faut se
souvenir qu'il ya 23 ans à la première
élection les socialistes faisait partie
de la majorité du général de gaulle
ce n'est qu'après qu'ils s'en sont
détachés reste que à six élections
consécutives
les électeurs ont confirmé renvoyer la
même ou presque la même majorité
or hier la vente a changé de camp et la
même proportion importante car la gauche
n'avait jamais pu faire plus de 46 ou 47
% depuis le retour du général de gaulle
aux affaires et la bondi hier à 50 2%
or cinq ou six points pour la france
c'était beaucoup
alors les raisons il ya d'abord
évidemment la volonté de changement
alors la première raison la plus
générale je pensais la volonté le
changement l'aspiration au changement ou
vient d'en voir toutes sortes de
témoignages on en a vu les impressions
c'est d'ailleurs un besoin périodiques
en quelque sorte qui s'est exprimé en
d'autres temps et s'est porté sur
d'autres en 58 sur le général de gaulle
eux en 68 a pris d'autres formes
en 74 à une façon sûre valéry giscard
d'estaing
sept ans plus tard il ne pouvait plus
apparaître comme le candidat du
changement et c'est peut-être une
indication que c'est ans et ses longues
pour un septennat ça ça use le pouvoir
et puis une seconde raison qui paraît
évidente à travers au travers les
commentaires que nous faisions avec nos
copains les divisions de la majorité
je crois que il ne faut pas négliger cet
aspect là c'est cette majorité elle est
au fond divisé presque depuis 1974 le
parti gaulliste n'a jamais accepté
d'être écarté du pouvoir en 1914 est par
contre les partisans de valéry giscard
d'estaing ont espéré en rééquilibrant la
majorité devenir la majorité de la
majorité depuis deux ans ça s'est
aggravé et ses divisions et la carte le
montre bien
c'est que c'est généralement dans les
bastions les plus gaulliste ou les plus
chiraquien qui a eu un déficit il ya eu
un déchet et peut-être que si la
totalité des voix s'étaient reportés sur
valéry giscard d'estaing l'écart serait
beaucoup plus étroit puis dernière
raison l'affaiblissement du pc alors
l'assainissement les facteurs que nous
venons d'énumérer ils sont anciens en
fait il était au travail depuis
longtemps
celui ci est plus récent c'est la
surprise c'est l'événement inopinés ya
quinze jours
l'affaiblissement du parti communiste
qui retire à valéry giscard d'estaing
son principal argument la peur du
communisme car la thèse selon laquelle
le parti socialiste est l'otage du parti
communiste n'est plus guère crédible
alors la conséquence de ces facteurs
concourant c'est que l'homme qui depuis
16 ans était par son initiative
personnelle
le chef reconnu de l'opposition qui
avait réussi à refaire du vieux parti
socialiste dont il n'est peut-être pas
inutile de rappeler ce soir qu'en 1969
il ya douze ans son candidat avait
obtenu 5% à les suivre
âge au premier tour dont il a refait un
parti une force importante est
aujourd'hui accède au pouvoir et
recueille l'héritage du général de
gaulle alfie il faut prêter aussi évoqué
les mouvements inverses il faut des très
rares mais il ya eu cas du var par
exemple qui t'attire françois mitterrand
et puis qui est re devenu giscard diriez
aussi le cas alors là beaucoup plus
nette de tous les départements
d'outre-mer qui sans exception sont allé
à valérie rabassa ce qui n'était pas le
cas il y à 7 ans d'être clos à la
martinique qu'on savait déjà
on savait que françois mitterrand serait
élu résultats contradictoires avec le
vote des départements antillais
largement en faveur de valéry giscard
d'estaing scrutin il faut l'ajouter qui
a connu une très forte abstention près
de 50% après l'étonnement
ce fut la joie sans mesure des partisans
de françois mitterrand
je n'osais pas y croire
c'était l'évènement mystery jets
conscience quant à l'envi que l
événement historique
aussi la première fois grâce à cette
victoire de la gauche
harry
on peut on doit
l'événement très important
bien sûr au regard des décalages entre
une opinion publique
je me suis donc dit et alain martinez
les raisons en sont claires
les marques ukr mis en condition par le
colonialisme désorientés par de chômage
en plus c'est tromper mais nous au bpm
lavaud conscience d'avoir vu jusque vers
a fait confiance aux travailleurs de
france
en martinique les résultats du deuxième
tour ont confirmé la vague en faveur de
monsieur giscard d'estaing après une
campagne qui a porté surtout sur le
statut des départements d'outre-mer
les socialistes est il que la majorité à
manipuler la population en faisant
croire à des contre vérités notamment
que voter mitterrand c'était voter pour
l'indépendance alors que la grande
majorité des habitants reste attaché à
la départementalisation le thème de
l'avenir des départements d'outre-mer
sera à nouveau au coeur du débat qui
alimentera la campagne des législatives
et certains pensent que la dynamique qui
apportait françois mitterrand la
présidence rejaillira jusqu'aux antilles
lémanique et sur la bord des
légitimistes et ils sont plus pour la
départementalisation que pour quel que
soit l'homme qu'il incarne la preuve est
que quand c'était chaban delmas en avant
des chaban delmas qui oppose otage les
estimations constat était jusqu'à
redescend à voter giscard d'estaing
demain si c'est mitterrand sûrement
votre à mitterrand aujourd'hui les
antillais avec leur vote en porte-à-faux
se sentent un peu plus éloigné de la
métropole ce qu'ils vont demander très
vite au nouveau président c'est de les
rassurer
voilà tout doucement nous sommes
éloignés la métropole et nous pourrions
maintenant aborder les réactions à
l'étranger première d'entre elles celle
de washington avec ce message de
chaleureuses félicitations les
présidents reagan à françois mitterrand
mais le département d'état attend de
connaître la proposition du futur
gouvernement pour se prononcer
définitivement
pékin fidèle à la tradition annoncer
l'événement mais n'a pas fait de
commentaire même chose pour moscou avec
quand même déjà et c'est très net un
changement de ton dans la promenade qui
compte après l'élection de mitterrand
qui avait manifesté clairement sa
préférence avant le scrutin pour
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
n'avait pas ménagé ses critiques au
leader socialiste a adressé à françois
mitterrand un message de félicitations
dans laquelle il formule l'espoir de
voir la france et l'union soviétique
continuer d'oeuvrer pour une meilleure
compréhension entre l'est et l'ouest
la france a été souvent cité comme le
partenaire exemplaire de l'ue dans le
domaine de la détente mais aujourd'hui
les dirigeants soviétiques cendres
inquiète entre différents risques d'être
un interlocuteur plus difficile que
leopard est à la face à moscou
et si certains observateurs le premier
commentaire sur l'élection de françois
mitterrand à l'enfance a attribué ce
matin-là 17 du pays dans les cars destin
ou mécontentement populaire et la
volonté de changement des français la
page est tournée et le kremlin va devoir
maintenant traiter avec celui ci
l'accusé il ya quelques jours seulement
savoir faire glisser à droite le parti
beaucoup de messages de félicitations en
provenance du continent africain
commencer par ceux d'abdou diouf au
sénégal et du président chadli en
algérie messages de félicitations
également de juan carlos en espagne
mario soares ce qu est un général du
parti socialiste portugais a pris
l'avion tout à l'heure pour paris afin
de rencontrer les amis socialistes pour
fêter l'événement autre réaction
européenne celle de bonnes avec michel
meyer certainement pour voiler une
énorme surprise
on parle ici d'une élection tout à fait
spectaculaire d'une élection historique
en définitive la victoire de françois
mitterrand a totalement pris à
contre-pied et helmut schmidt et son
gouvernement
on ne s'attendait pas à ce résultat
peut-être aussi à cause que l'on ne
pouvait que l'on voulait peut-être aussi
se l'imaginer et si je reprends
maintenant les réactions officielles
c'est à dire le télégramme de helmut
schmidt à françois mitterrand télégramme
de félicitations il y a dans ce
télégramme le désir d'une rencontre très
prochaine entre les deux hommes ainsi
qu'une volonté de favoriser le site
l'entente franco allemande
de son côté billy bragg s'est réduit au
cours d'une interview que nous avons
diffusé ce midi de la victoire de son
ami françois mitterrand dans le même
temps il a estimé au cours de cette
interview devoir avoir éventuellement
d'intermédiaire entre le chancelier
schmitt et le nouveau président français
les maîtres mots aujourd'hui en
allemagne pour réagir en quelque sorte à
cette élection française
eh bien ce sont les suivants si j'en
crois la presse surprise attentes
expectative quant à l'évolution d'une
france où vient de se produire selon le
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung la des
journaux les plus suivis d'allemagne un
événement de portée incalculable
également un message de salut aux
félicitations provenance de man sa
chaire l'andrh même chose pour les
ambassadeurs arabes en poste à paris
avec un souhait que françois mitterrand
disciples et mes interprétations que
peuvent empêcher sa politique au proche
orient
du côté de ménard nber guînes en
revanche en israël pas de réserves
hier c'est en israël même si l'on prend
parfois des précautions oratoires pour
ne pas avoir l'air de s'ingérer dans les
affaires intérieures françaises
on se réjouit ouvertement défection
françois-mitterand à la présidence de la
république
on y voit l'occasion de retrouvailles
profonde entre la france et israël
on espère que la france soutiendrait les
accords de camp david et se rapprochera
des positions de l'état hébreu dans le
conflit israélo arabe
le premier ministre menahem begin de la
confirmer tout à l'heure à la sortie de
son bureau
monsieur françois
mais voilà qui a marqué les horreurs
miche notre machine nous sommes très
heureux de l'élection d'un homme que je
connais depuis 30 ans qui est un grand
ami d'israël
il est contre la coopération nucléaire
française avec nos ennemis et je ne
retire rien de ce que j'ai dit la
semaine dernière que monsieur giscard
d'estaing qui n'est pas vraiment un ami
d'israël et du peuple juif alors jusqu'à
deux fois ci le grand israël s'attend
donc à un resserrement significatif des
relations entre les deux pays
et monsieur françois mitterrand est
d'ores et déjà invités à visiter israël
bien avec nous comme invité pour parler
précisément de politique étrangère avec
dans le nouveau septennat de françois
mitterrand
tout chez son que l'on présente parfois
comme le futur mini dv étrangères enfin
c'est pas l'essentiel l'essentiel vais
vous soyez l'année conseiller privilégié
de françois mitterrand dans ce domaine
vous êtes en poste à bruxelles vous
connaissez bien les problèmes européens
c'est donc là dessus qu'on va vous
interrogez avec des questions concrètes
que peuvent se poser les agriculteurs
français qui vous le savez de ménage
n'allons pas tellement voter socialiste
hier il se pose des questions qu'est ce
que ça a changé pour eux
que va changer l'élection de françois
mitterrand quand on la politique
agricole commune
le futur président il était candidat à
ce moment là on a parlé très clairement
il s'est référé à un document qui a été
produit par edgard pisani et par
d'autres camarades du parti socialiste
et qui présente à mon avis une thèse
global très intéressantes sur l'ensemble
a political commune
il faut réviser la politique agricole
commune
c'est à dire il faut l'élargir
l'expérience de toutes ces années de
marché commun montre que cette politique
a amené les résultats importants pour la
france mais pas seulement pour la ligue
2 française pour l'agriculture
européenne
l'aviculture est devenu un des éléments
de force de l'europe
c'est un fait mais l'élargissement
inquiètes plutôt certains un moment où
certains souhaiteraient par exemple se
débarrasser de la grande bretagne vous
propose élargie à d'autres
égouttez nous parlons l'élargissement
séparément si vous voulez bien à mon
avis on ne peut parler de
l'élargissement de manière rationnelle
que si on a traité d'abord les problèmes
qui se posent à la communauté telle
qu'elle est
cette communauté n'est pas capable de
traiter ces problèmes
je ne vois pas comment elle pourra
accepter l'élargissement dans les
conditions qui politiquement s'impose il
faut donc compléter la politique
agricole commune en compensant certaines
faiblesses on ne joue actuellement que
par les prix et les stocks ça ne suffit
pas on est obligé de faire des prix pour
les petits producteurs pour qu'ils
survivent et alors on donne aux gros des
profits tout à fait des mesures et nous
n'aurons pas de politique extérieure
dans ce domaine alors que les américains
et d'autres en ont c'est une erreur
incompréhensible
il ya des domaines entiers qui n'ont pas
été couverts et amp actuel de 22 la
pêche
il faut donc compléter la politique
agricole commune là-dessus françois
mitterrand a été tout à fait clairs dans
quel délai vu son arrivée il faut tirer
vais très vite et je vais vous dire que
sur ce point les anglais vont nous aider
une fois n'est pas coutume ils vont nous
aider parce qu'ils veulent traiter leurs
problèmes budgétaires et qu'il est tout
à fait exclu que l'on traite le problème
budgétaire en soit il faut traiter des
politiques de l'europe est naturellement
d'abord de la consolidation de la seule
politique qui existait jusqu'à
maintenant la politique agricole et
après nous enverrons les conséquences
budgétaires mais sur la pêche par
exemple on va re négocié avec les
anglais sur la pêche ont été
pratiquement au bout de la négociation
pratiquement au bout alors pourrait
aborder maintenant une autre domaine
celui des relations avec les états unis
visiblement l'embarras de washington
cache une certaine surprise il n'était
pas prévu qu'un président socialiste
soit élu la tête le petit pays qu'est ce
que ça va changer dans nos relations
avec l'europe avec le monde attends tu y
es permettait de le dire d'une boutade
les américains ont tout d'un coup il ya
quelques jours découvert qu'ils arrêtent
y avoir une élection importante en
france ils sont occupés et à des
domaines qui ne les avait guère
intéressé jusque là il faut dire qu'ils
ont eu la très grande émotion de
l'attentât contre le président reagan
et puis l'intérêt la fascination devant
ce programme regen la possibilité de
faire passer au congrès l'habileté du
président etc alors l'élection française
avait complètement disparu de la presse
de l'attention des américains et ceux
qui en avaient entendu parler croyais
que c'était une élection comme une autre
qu'on allait remplacer peut-être un
homme
par un autre moins que l'homme qui était
en place demeure il s'était pas du tout
rendu compte qu'il pouvait y avoir à la
faveur de cette élection un changement
profond alors un saut vers ce qui pour
eux est l'inconnu on a l'impression si
je puis dire que justement les
dirigeants américains savent pas très
bien par quel bout il faut prendre
françois mitterrand parce que d'un côté
ya son alliance avec les communistes qui
inquiète et de l'autre par son
atlantisme supposé qui les rassure alors
qu'elle est quelle est la bonne façon
d'aborder françois mitterrand pour les
américains il ya un élément sûr pour les
américains qui est l'importance que
françois mitterrand attache à l'alliance
atlantique
il l'a montré dans sa vie et il l'a
répété aisne puis une fois pendant toute
la campagne
ceci est pour les américains un élément
sûr il ya un élément qui peut être les
inquiète mais qui à mon avis devrait les
rassurer
c'est la volonté affirmée par le nouveau
président quand il était candidat
d'avoir avec les principaux partenaires
de l'alliance une discussion
fondamentale sur le contenu de
l'alliance
jusqu'où va telle que comporte-t-elle
est il acceptable quand on est dans une
alliance que certains et des attitudes
prennent des décisions qui affectent
gravement les intérêts des autres sans
en tenir le moins du monde compte qu'à
françois mitterrand est exactement là
dessus je n'en sais rien mais je penche
personnellement qu'il serait bon en
effet de parler avec les alliés de
l'alliance atlantique des grands
problèmes économiques qui nous affecte
et sur lequel l'opposition sont à
l'heure actuelle très différentes et que
vous cessiez lit vous avez la même
tendresse pour le cabinet reagan avait
apparemment bélesta destin écoutez je
propose que au début tout au moins ses
problèmes de tendresse pour des hommes
ou des cabinets soit le point important
bien sûr pour vous c'est plus facile
d'expliquer les problèmes en les
personnalisant à l'extrême
mon enfant du musée personnes ne sont
intéressantes que dans la mesure où
s'expriment des politiques
je trouve le message du chancelier
schmidt tout aussi affectueux mais
aujourd'hui qu'il aurait pu ladrière
monsieur j'ai cependant l'impression
quand même et paradoxalement peut-être
qu'il y aura plus de facilité
établir de bonnes relations avec
washington qu avec moscou il y aura mon
avis plus de facilité à établir un vrai
dialogue avec washington a parlé
sérieusement des problèmes nous avons
là-bas une nouvelle administration qu'il
veut définir une politique n'a pas
encore fait dans beaucoup de domaines
mais elles veulent à définir nous avons
en france un président qui a annoncé
qu'il voulait définir des politiques
donc le dialogue va s'établir la
facilité le dialogue doit être beaucoup
plus grande quand ce dialogue s'établira
ne nous faisons pas d'illusions il y
aura des difficultés
la difficulté principale faudrait
l'expliquer en terme relativement
généraux que représente le vote français
d'hier il augmente une volonté de
changement
la france est le premier pays occidental
à le faire admet que nous sommes dans
une époque différente des années 50 60
et que on aura beau faire de l'austérité
lutter contre l'inflation utilisée tous
les trucs qu'on a appris à l'université
on ne reviendra pas aux années 50 60 le
monde d'aujourd'hui n'est plus le monde
d'il ya 20 ans l'ordre monétaire est
différent les pays du tiers monde compte
l'énergie ne n'a plus le même prix la
prévisibilité des grands marchés
n'existe plus de la même manière nous
sommes dans un monde différent
tous sont sucrés cela la majorité hier
l'a remarqué en choisissant un homme
nouveau pour une politique nouvelle
ceci ne va pas se limiter à l'intérieur
de la france disant jugement difficultés
et coaching tonnes par exemple sur le
tiers-monde
il peut y avoir des difficultés avec
washington sur certains sujets vous me
dites sur le tiers-monde pour le moment
la thèse américaine et que la relance
économique indispensable se fera à
partir des marchés des pays
industrialisés par une valorisation de
ses marchés et cela en utilisant les
forces du marché dans un hyper
libéralisme personnellement je ne pense
pas que ça soit possible
je ne pense pas que ça soit possible
pour des pays qui n'ont pas des
ressources suffisantes
un marché d'une dimension suffisante
nous avons besoin des marchés du
tiers-monde
nous avons besoin d'une sécurité dans
deux rapports avec le tiers-monde
quant à nos approvisionnements quant à
l'écoulement d'un certain nombre
nos produits nos départs ça coûte cher
le tiers-monde ça coûte chirac qui
brassent que je voulais savoir vous avez
à l'heure actuelle une situation tout à
fait paradoxale il n'y a jamais eu
autant d'argent dans le monde les pays
pétroliers produisent un surplus de pro
disons 130 140 milliards de dollars
cette année qu'ils n'utiliseront pas cet
argent est flottant il est stérilisé
pendant le même temps vous avez dans une
partie du monde une avidité de
financement pour permettre un
développement pour permettre un
accroissement des marchés vous permettre
des importations plus grande plus
nombreuses
c'est un des paradoxes extraordinaire de
la période actuelle si glee inflation
dans les sociétés industrialisées
il y as déflation au niveau mondial
alors ne peut-on pas utilisé peut-on pas
utiliser ces sommes considérables qui
sont disponibles les patrons des grands
organismes financiers internationaux ont
proposé les méthodes ont pas qu'on
puisse dire que monsieur mcnamara ou que
monsieur de larosière notre compatriote
soit des révolutionnaires
ils ont proposé les méthodes mais ses
méthodes il faut les mettre en oeuvre
tout de suite et ils représenteront
quelques centaines de milliards de
francs de francs actuels de relance
d'entièrement temps nous savons très
bien que les fournisseurs seront nos
propres pays c'est un élément de la
relance
ça n'est pas un élément qu'accepte les
américains aujourd'hui parce que ce mode
de faire ne leur permet pas ce qu'ils
appellent la sélectivité en action dans
tiers monde c'est à dire le choix entre
les bons et les mauvais claude cheysson
l'évoquer et l'europe l'amérique le
tiers-monde reste du rss on peut pas
dire que moscou est vraiment souhaiter
la victoire de françois mitterrand
penser que ça vous posera des problèmes
dans les relations à venir avec lui un
test
moi je ne suis pas dans le secret du
kremlin et je ne sais absolument pas ce
qu'a souhaité ce que n'a pas souhaité
leur iceberg da paraissait évident ce
que je dirais c'est que a priori un
gouvernement qui a des politiques très
stable pour ne pas dire conservatrice
doit craindre le changement et que donc
l'élection d'un homme qui représente le
changement est un élément d'inquiétude
pour tout ce qu'il ya de conservateurs
dans le monde
il est possible que le kremlin doivent
être pris dans ce
groupe et les pays arabes monsieur chez
sont et ce qu'ils vont un peu se
rétracter de voir arriver au pouvoir
françois mitterrand que monsieur begin
vient de qualifier deux amis véritables
d'israël je veux pas commenter les
propos de monsieur begin ni seul
aujourd'hui ni ce qu'il ya quelques
jours qu'ils ont parfois été surprenant
dans leur forme vous le reconnaîtrez les
pays arabes sont évidemment inquiets de
l'arrivée d'un nouveau venu nouveau venu
je veux dire un homme qui n'a pas encore
été au pouvoir
d'un autre côté les pays arabes ne
peuvent pas oublier qu'à travers toute
sa campagne françois mitterrand a
beaucoup insisté sur le fait que la
france celle qu'il l'avoir doit
respecter deux grandes règles de droit
qui n'était pas acceptable que en
fonction d'intérêts immédiat nous les
oublions totalement ici ou là or les
pays arabes
quand ils présentent leur thèse les
présente souvent précisément au nom du
droit des peuples
donc c'est un élément qui pèsera
incontestablement ça veut dire un petit
peu tout de même un rééquilibrage de la
politique française en faveur d'israël
je n'en sais rien nous verrons
d'ailleurs surtout ses problèmes de
politique étrangère la vème république a
donné au président de la république des
pouvoirs considérables je serais étonné
que le président mitterrand ne les
utilise pas comme l'ont fait ses
prédécesseurs une toute dernière
question compte les entraînements vous
allez vous y prendre pour harry gow
partenaires communistes faire une
déclaration sur l'afghanistan par
exemple abord la question devrait être
posée au président au futur président
est pas à moi qui suis pour le moment
membre de la commission européenne et
rien d'autre deuxièmement je n'imagine
pas un instant que les positions du
président françois mitterrand puissent
être différentes des positions du
candidat françois mitterrand or ses
positions sur l'afghanistan ont été
parfaitement clair
donc je ne peux pas imaginer d'autres
déclarations de la part du président de
la république demain que celle que nous
avons entendues depuis quelques semaines
du candidat claude cheysson jour merci
d'avoir été notre invité
samak que nous reparlerons de vous nous
on va reparler de boudin dans les
semaines à venir et puisque nous parlons
de l'actualité à l'étranger sache et les
tirs ont repris au liban à beyrouth et
dans la région de tille
pour le ministre israélien menahem begin
nous y faisions allusion tout à l'heure
a révélé qu'une opération contre les
missiles syriens avaient été différées
par deux fois enfin en france seule
information notable de la journée outre
les présidentielles un attentat dans le
tgv qui circulent entre paris et lyon
une bombe a éclaté en début d'après midi
alors que le convoi se trouvait en seine
et marne à la hauteur de montereau il y
a eu quatre blessés légers ils ont déjà
quitté l'hôpital ce soir c'est un
mystérieux groupe jacques mesrine qui
revendique sept ans
voilà pour l'essentiel de l'actualité ce
soir mais nous ne saurions pas complet
sans la météo même à 20h59 lancia
laurent broomhead absolument et
malheureusement c'est le mauvais temps
qui continue une zone de basse pression
et sur la france une dépression dans les
nuages ne passe pas d'ouest en est ou du
sud est vers le nord-ouest et bien il
tourbillonne sur place qui fait que nous
restons sous les nuages et sous la pluie
température du même coup ont subi une
baisse aujourd'hui à 14 heures nous
allons voir la carte relevé par la
métrologie nationale voyez c'est un peu
plus faible clients même si vers 16
heures elle avait quelque peu remonté
que tout de même extrêmement douces pour
la saison
la carte des prévisions pour demain sur
l'ensemble du pays ainsi elle
extrêmement nuageuse souvent couverts il
est plus intermittentes parfois
orageuses sur les massifs montagneux et
puis quelques éclaircies çà va pas vous
dire où parce que je ne le sais pas et
nuages tourbillonne dans tous les sens
et les vents seront eux aussi dans tous
les sens demain les températures prévues
pour demain peu près semblable à celle
d'aujourd'hui de 10 degrés environ lever
du jour jusqu'à 18 degrés à peu près
l'après midi puis la donne
c'est la saint achille voilà avec cette
météo logique asie politiques nous ont
fait le tour complet de l'actualité en
une heure donc avec ce journal
exceptionnel pour un événement
exceptionnel bien entendu la victoire de
françois mitterrand qui donc va devenir
président de la république dans quelques
jours désormais à 23 heures
vous avez rendez vous avec pierre alain
et puis demain à 12h45 antenne 2010
bonsoir à tous à demain 20 h